Robert was asked to find where G of X
which is equal to the cube root of x has
inflection points
this is his solution and then later we
are asked is robert's work correct if
not what's his mistake so pause this
video and try to figure it out on your
own all right now let's work through
this together so our original G of X is
equal to the cube root of x which is the
same thing as X to the one-third so in
step one it looks like Roberts trying to
find the first and second derivative so
the first trivet if we just do the power
rule so we'll be one-third x to the
decrement the exponent so this is
looking good second derivative we take
this multiply this times one third which
would be negative two nights and then
decrement negative 2/3 which would
indeed be negative five-thirds so that
looks right and then it looks like
Roberts trying to rewrite it so we have
the negative 2/9 still but then he
recognized that this is the same thing
as X to the 5/3 in the denominator and X
to the 5/3 is the same thing as X as the
cube root of x to the fifth so this is
all looking good step one looks good and
then step two it looks like he's trying
to find the solution or he's trying to
find x values where the second
derivative is equal to zero and it is
indeed true that the second that this
has no solution that you can never make
this second derivative equal to zero in
order to be zero the numerator would
have to be zero and well 2 is never
going to be equal to zero so this is
correct and then step three he says G
doesn't have any inflection points now
this is a little bit suspect it is in
many cases our inflection point is a
situation where our second derivative is
equal to zero and even then we don't
know it's an inflection point it would
be a candidate inflection point we would
have to confirm that our second
derivative crosses signs or switches
signs as we cross that x value but here
we can't find a situation where a second
derivative is equal to zero but we have
to remind ourselves that other candidate
inflection points are where our second
derivative is undefined and so he can't
make this statement without seeing where
our second derivative could be undefined
so for example he could say that G prime
prime is
undefined undefined when what well this
is going to be undefined when X is equal
to 0 X 0 to the fifth cube root of that
that's going to be 0 but then you're
dividing by 0 so G prime prime undefined
when X is equal to 0 so therefore x
equals so we could say candidate
candidate candidate inflection point
when x equals 0 and so then we would
want to test it and we could set up a
traditional table that you might have
seen before where we have our interval
or intervals we could have test values
and our intervals and we have to be
careful with those make sure that they
are indicative and then we would say the
sign of our second derivative of G prime
prime and then we would have our
concavity concavity of G and in order
for x equals 0 to be an inflection point
we would have to switch signs as our
second derivative would have to switch
signs as we cross x equals 0 and R which
would mean our concavity of G switches
signs as we go as we cross x equals 0 so
let's do values less than 0 negative
infinity to 0 and then values greater
than 0 infinity 0 to infinity I could do
test values let's say I'll use negative
1 and 1 and you have to be careful when
you use these you have to make sure that
we are close enough that nothing nothing
unusual happens between these test
values up until we get to that candidate
inflection point and now what's the sign
of our second derivative when X is equal
to negative 1 when x equals negative 1
so let's see negative 1 to the fifth
power is negative 1 cube root of
negative 1 is negative 1 and so we're
gonna have negative 2/9 divided by
negative 1 it's gonna be positive two
nights so our sign right over here is
going to be positive and when and this
is going to be in general when we're
dealing with any negative value because
if you take any negative value to the
fifth power it's going to be negative
and then you take that the cube root of
that you're gonna have negative but then
you have a negative value divided by
that you're gonna get a positive value
so you can feel good that this test
value is indicative of actually this
entire interval and if you're dealing
with a positive value well that to the
fifth power is going to be positive cube
root of that still going to be positive
but then you're gonna have negative 2/9
divided by that positive value so this
is going to be negative so it is indeed
the case that our concavity of G
switches as we cross x equals zero or
concave upwards when X is less than zero
our second derivative is positive and we
are concave downwards when X is greater
than zero let me write that a little bit
downwards down words when X is greater
than 0 so we are switching concavity as
we cross x equals zero and so this tells
us that X so let's see we are switching
signs switching let me say G prime prime
switching signs as we cross x equals
zero and our function is defined at x
equals zero and function defined at x
equals zero so we have an inflection
point at x equals zero so inflection
point at x is equal to zero and if
you're familiar with the graph of the
cube root you would indeed see an
inflection point at that point so there
we go he was wrong in step three there
actually is an inflection point it's not
when the second derivative is equal to
zero it's actually where the second
derivative is undefined